[Música]
vamos a hablar de el futuro de la
producción agrícola de la producción de
alimentos vamos a hablar de esos
alimentos que son muy importantes para
esas cadenas alimenticias importantes no
quiero decir que es a este melón fresco
esa flotilla que fue cultivada muy cerca
de las casas de ustedes o del restaurant
a donde fueron a comer no sea importante
es sumamente importante pero hoy día me
gustaría hablar de aquellos alimentos
que son producidos en forma extensiva en
grandes haciendas porque ellos son el
fundamento de estas cadenas alimenticias
que alimentan a mucha gente por ejemplo
la soya como proteína vegetal
que alimenta aves cerdos y estos son la
proteína animal que alimenta al gran a
gran cantidad de millones de chinos por
ejemplo o el maíz que es fundamental
para la cadena alimenticia que genera la
carne la carne de bovino que se produce
a gran escala y hablando de alimentarse
quién de ustedes se echó algo a la boca
hoy día para alimentarse levanten la
mano
bien pocas dietas no
y me gustaría saber también otra
pregunta muy simple y quiere que ustedes
vieron han visto los últimos dos tres
meses un bebé recién nacido
varias ustedes tenían poca
tenía pocas y si tenía boca no es cierto
lo que quiero decir es que nosotros
tenemos una población que demanda
alimento y díaz y va a demandar mucho
alimento porque esta población está
creciendo vamos a ver un estimaciones
entre 9 y 10 millones de personas en el
año 2030 2050 bueno 2018 son 30 años
hasta entonces pero la evolución de la
agricultura de la producción de
alimentos se mueve muy lentamente tanto
por un tema cultural
donde los agricultores los productores
son de alguna manera lentos para adoptar
tecnologías quieren ver los resultados y
también por el ciclo de año a año donde
las cosas que hacemos hoy día no las
podemos probar y ver que tienen
resultado hasta el próximo año
y eso ha traído muchas preocupaciones
gobiernos organizaciones no
gubernamentales grandes empresas están
todos preocupados habrá suficiente
tierra está en imdb exterminaremos los
recursos naturales
vamos a seguir destinando a la selva
amazónica y grandes preocupaciones pero
yo quiero ponernos hoy día e invitarlos
a ponernos en los zapatos del productor
de quien individuo que eligió
producir alimentos para ganarse el día
y esa persona también tiene muchas
preocupaciones cuál es la variedad que
plantó cuáles son los procedimientos que
tengo que usar para que crezca ese
alimento idea tener personas que me van
a ayudar para hacer todas estas tareas
que hay en el campo qué pasa con toda
esa gente que sigue yéndose de la ciudad
del campo sí a la ciudad
y ahí nosotros tenemos a nuestros
productores con muchas dudas
hoy quiero traerles un mensaje optimista
porque tenemos grandes avances
tecnológicos y algunos otros factores de
los cuales les voy a hablar que nos
hacen pensar que la producción de
alimentos si bien no está asegurada pero
vamos a tener
comida buena comida de diversidad que
nos va a alimentar a nosotros que esos 2
millones de personas que van a nacer de
que hasta el 2050 entonces vamos a ver
cuáles son esos son tres áreas
principales de las que vamos a hablar
hoy día
la primera
es la genética
pero después de haber visto las charlas
de hoy día yo tendría que tener mucho
coraje
tendría que tener o tener vergüenza para
poder hablar de genética con los
investigadores con los médicos con los
biólogos que nos han dado charlas
fantásticas hoy día así que vamos sólo a
decir que la genética ha producido cada
vez variedades de los más importantes
cultivos con mayor y mayor productividad
a lo largo del ciclo así que hemos visto
hay un crecimiento lineal en casi todas
las culturas nuestros los cultivos otro
donde cual les puedo dar un poco más es
la mecanización y vamos a hablar
justamente de máquinas cada día más auto
automáticas cada día más eficaz es cada
día más productivas
pero otra ola que está realmente
impactando la agricultura es la
digitalización en otras palabras tenemos
toda la conectividad que desde las
máquinas de clima de muchos otros
elementos en el campo están llevando ese
mundo real ese mundo físico a un mundo
digital y por ejemplo cuando nosotros
interpretamos
la mecanización con la digitalización
entramos en una área que la agricultura
se llama agricultura de precisión que en
realidad es bastante simple se trata de
poner el insumo correcto con la cantidad
correcta en el momento correcto en el
lugar correcto y de la manera correcta
parece simple pero este es un campo de
desarrollo de tecnología de la
agricultura que continúa mejorando
continúa avanzando pero todavía hay
mucho por hacer por ejemplo nosotros
vemos en esa foto que las semillas están
plantadas a una distancia
agronómicamente óptima
para maximizar la productividad de esa
cosecha pero al mismo tiempo donde se
cruzan las líneas no tenemos semillas
duplicadas así que podemos ahorrar
también en los costos de semillas que
por la genética son cada día más caras
pero al día al mismo tiempo con mayor
potencial
en la parte de aplicación de químicos y
de fertilizantes estos aún más
importantes porque hasta ahora en la
mayoría de las haciendas el método que
se usa es un método de fuerza bruta
donde tenemos anchas máquinas que van
aplicando cantidades similares pero eso
es un enfoque que sería muy parecido a
que si en la ciudad de san josé de costa
rica tuviéramos algunos focos de
enfermedad y les diéramos antibióticos a
todos a todos ustedes también
ya escuchamos el problema de la
resistencia hemos escuchado el problema
del exceso de usos antibióticos así que
aquí tenemos mucho que hacer déjenme
mostrarle dos ejemplos de tecnologías
que están haciendo que esta mecanización
y esta digitalización
se junten para reducir la cantidad de
insumos que estamos echándole a la
agricultura
e insumos que cuando están bien
aplicados no están cuadros que para esto
parecen cuadros esto parece realmente
una ilustración pero es justamente el
uso del piloto automático ustedes van a
ver ahí que están cada uno de los
cuadros plantados muy bien y hasta las
huellas de gps del pelo de las máquinas
que siguen justamente las huellas de
guiados por gps
esa es una tecnología que ya está
muchísimos años pero vienen otras más
interesantes aún
cuando nosotros tomamos la capacidad de
inteligencia artificial redes neuronales
profundas y aprendizaje de máquinas y
las traemos de los laboratorios y las
integramos en una máquina que es capaz
de detectar una maleza de una planta
estos sistemas pasan por un montón de
entrenamiento le mostramos a estas
máquinas muchísimas fotos de malezas y
muchísimas fotos de plantas y finalmente
tiene la capacidad de discriminar entre
una y otra entonces en este caso esta
máquina toma la identificación de la
planta y si es maleza castilla un
chorrito
de químico para solamente deshacerse de
la maleza y el resto del cultivo ya no
tiene más esa aplicación el ahorro es de
más del 90 por ciento del insumo pero
más importante y pienso no estamos
colocando más químicos de los que
realmente se necesitan para producir con
calidad
tecnología
que está saliendo de los laboratorios y
de aplicaciones en la ciudad en la
industria en finanzas y que están
llegando a soluciones muy simples para
ayudar a ese productor de que les hable
para aplicar el químico exactamente
donde tiene que ser aplicado y no más de
lo que tiene que ser aplicado
la última charla de la sección anterior
habló de robótica
esta máquina no es una máquina que sea
agrícola es una máquina robótica que
corta el pasto en residencias y los voy
a tomar por un pequeño desvío porque en
realidad vamos a volver a la agricultura
en un momento pero para quienes que
participamos en este proyecto de tomar
tecnologías meterlas en un producto que
se venda fue como un precalentamiento
como justo antes de un partido de fútbol
súper importante que la gente calienta
un poquito bueno eso fue lo que hicimos
acá y claro que también tiene una
propuesta de valor importante le ahorra
tiempo a la gente para adquirirlos
pueden ir a jugar fútbol con los hijos
no pueden ir a jugar a andar en
motocicleta o también para que el hombre
tenga tiempo para tomarse una copa de
vino con la esposa y hacer lo que viene
después de eso se acuerdan de la primera
charla d amico o algo así
bueno volvamos volvamos al partido
principal aquí tenemos un prototipo de
una de las grandes compañías de
fabricación de máquinas agrícolas que
está mostrando cómo vamos a ayudarle al
productor a compensar por esa falta de
mano de obra y para hacer que el trabajo
en el campo sea hecho con algún más
precisión
y para aquellos están preocupados de la
carne hablamos de la carne todo esto de
agricultura de precisión la
digitalización la mecanización no
solamente se aplica a la producción de
cultivos también la ganadería está
pasando por una revolución donde en vez
de trabajar con un rebaño de cientos de
cabezas y aplicarle las mismas dietas de
alimento y los mismos antibióticos como
escuchamos antes ahora estamos tratando
cada uno de ellos gracias a tener
sensores en los animales
lugares donde los podemos pensar día a
día y entender qué está pasando con cada
uno de ellos para que podamos tener
justamente animal tras animal salud
y mecanización genética digitalización
están haciendo que la producción de
alimentos continúe creciendo pero quiero
llevarlos a un mapa para mostrarles
dónde está la siguiente frontera
de crecimiento exponencial de la
agricultura y eso es donde estamos
parados hoy día los trópicos
y porque en los trópicos porque los
trópicos nosotros tenemos la intensidad
solar que permite que crezcan las
plantas la fotosíntesis ocurre a lo
largo del año
y es latinoamérica donde ese milagro y
ese crecimiento está ocurriendo ahora en
áfrica va a ocurrir pero áfrica estas
décadas atrasadas y otros lugares como
por ejemplo india sufren todo y todavía
de la pulverización de la propiedad
agrícola producto de reformas agrarias
entonces podemos contar por en cuanto en
latinoamérica
y por qué porque resulta que las
en los climas templados nosotros tenemos
un cultivo un cultivo de soya o un
cultivo del país- que va a ocupar entre
40 o 60 por ciento del tiempo del año y
el resto del tiempo esa tierra y queda
parada
pero en los climas tropicales podemos
utilizar un cultivo de soya después uno
de maíz utilizando más del 80% del
tiempo esa tierra fértil o incluso
podemos plantar con las técnicas más
modernas pasto junto con el maíz y
después podemos llevar grados y así la
tierra se beneficia no solamente de
producción en más del 90% sino que
además de eso del beneficio de la
rotación de cultivos que es muy sano y
la interacción entre el ganado y la
pradera que aumenta la salud del suelo
pero eso también trae complejidad y
ustedes aquí están viendo un escenario
que tiene muchas máquinas tratando de
cosechar ese grano que está
suficientemente seco pero al mismo
tiempo tiene que plantar inmediatamente
en un suelo que ojalá esté
suficientemente húmedo para la
germinación esto está generalmente más
allá del alcance de la mayoría de los
productores es muy complejo pero junto
con el desafío también está la
oportunidad y está la ayuda y un ejemplo
que les voy a dar en brasil en trapa
junto con una red de empresas privadas y
también otros organismos de gobierno a
desarrollar una promoción justamente
para motivar el uso de técnicas de
cultivo de agricultura tropical que
integra silvicultura bosques cultivos y
animales y esto está cubriendo ya más de
11 millones de hectáreas en brasil y más
todavía si contamos los países que están
circundantes así que hay esperanza y
apoyo para el productor
y hay otro factor que me gustaría
destacar
todos nuestros hijos la nueva generación
viene ya con una adopción de la
tecnología digital y ese factor del que
hablaba al principio de que los
productores son muy reacios a adoptar
tecnologías yo estoy confiado que este
es un punto de inflexión porque las
nuevas generaciones de productores van a
venir pidiendo nueva tecnología
y cómo va a venir esta tecnología de
dónde viene la ayuda nuestros países de
latinoamérica como lo hemos visto y
viene este de c's están hirviendo de
creatividad están hirviendo de
innovación las universidades están
creando mucho conocimiento hay
ecosistemas de empresas que están
creciendo startups y todo hace que sea
posible que llevemos tecnologías por
ejemplo muy complejas como de
inteligencia artificial a soluciones muy
simples para ayudar a ese productor
llevo cinco años en brasil trabajando
para innovar en latinoamérica en el
agronegocio
con investigadores en el campo y con
clientes en el campo para entender cómo
vamos a traer las mejores tecnologías
desarrolladas en el mundo entero para
aplicarlas y seguir en esta en este
camino de aumentar la producción de la
agricultura tropical
a mí me gustaría invitarlos a todos
ustedes quienes son inversionistas por
ejemplo que consideren la agricultura
como una fuente de futuros rendimientos
los académicos que están trabajando por
ejemplo en nuevas tecnologías de
inteligencia artificial que vean si hay
aplicaciones en el agro
para aquellos de ustedes que son
potenciales futuros productores que se
interesen hay mucha tierra todavía que
trabajar así que con eso los dejo con el
siguiente invitación vamos a trabajar
todos juntos vamos a traer lo mejor que
tenemos vamos a seguir desarrollando esa
agricultura tropical y juntos vamos a
alimentar el mundo que existe hoy y los
2 millones adicionales que vienen el
2050 muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]